I love chicken nuggets so much I don't
like them that much share the soul food
of fast-food chicken into sorbet baby
can't tell this one is McDonald's or
this this one is McDonald's 100% oh
these are McDonald's for sure feel like
you would find this in the dollar menu I
will say no with quality meat because
it's that pink whose stuff remember it's
like sweet childhood as a processed food
flavor that you want to spice yeah
Lupino yeah it's like just the right
amount like sodium please look at it
wine looks like a dinosaur ruin your
favorite so this one looks a little bit
more promising a little bit more cooked
I think their Burger King this one has a
little more salty it's got a little kick
to it
this is Burger King it's so good this
one tastes more like chicken crunchiness
geo spray this is amazing I can have
more of these these taste healthier than
this how cuz there's equity like a
chicken like I don't know like
fluffiness to it and this just tastes
like cardboard I don't know they're
represented by a little star at what
ages a country do we stop making food
into shapes
I'm a bomb oh they're headless stars
these tastes like straight from the
frozen food aisle
it's cruncher than the first one for a
Hong Kong this is a fish I'm just like
peeling off you like it eating oh it
looks good but it doesn't taste as good
because of the star shape you have one
service area because you have a star you
get more bready this is a perfect amount
of ready yeah you don't need more than
that know what this one is chick-fil-a
your feet on my favorite chick-fil-a I
know all right
this was definitely chicken definitely
tugging yeah I mean it's good um it's
just a little bit too much sodium for
man the perfect amount know what you're
talking about
yeah I think these are so better
this one's not as cute as this one those
ones will sleep all over the place used
to filthy reminds me of a high school
middle school elementary school
cafeteria food and here's like microwave
oven this is sad all right if that's
Wendy's I'm gonna be sad this one's my
favorite this one which I'm guessing is
windy this is the best one this is the
worst one I knew it I told her from did
you know it I thought BK and I will like
closer than that Oh what kind of you
think you know who your friends are and
they just slap you in the face
well let's keep it with the run house